oh what a dink what a lovely tank
hey Kelly he can't say take this series
over to first post apocalyptic mugging
I'm not a badass I would be I would be
um specs is in Mad Max is yeah he's the
organic organic oh sure he's one who
pulls the baby I was like playing with
the umbilical oh wow that's right it is
yeah I was so excited seeing Susan yeah
like that guy I'm a fan say yeah hey
well kids welcome we got a new backdrop
yeah yo yes it's a desert you know so uh
coming at you live and direct from Danks
through your tank studios in beautiful
downtown Burbank this is not downtown
Burbank is a reference to Jay Leno okay
it's up we're not done jayla Studios
weren't even downtown downtown me over
there and over there this is great
because it's right it's right behind
right behind right now the camera is
downtown where it were up to me yeah
we're downtown we're up town up town up
town girls I'm gonna love you in 20 dam
funk you up everything is uptown right
now yeah uptown everything is gas town
everything is gas town or the bullet
farm or the setae ttle citadels or the
green the green place hey man when they
run when he is there chasing him through
that this is a book a great
representative this is chase him to a
place where there's green [ __ ] yeah they
don't mention it again for like an hour
and then he's like no they are green
stuff yeah it's perfect at hey we're
gonna talk about man we're gonna talk
about mix mix max funky rump yeah mixmax
funky rump yeah so this is part one or
wallet back relax maybe crack a brew or
a soda pop as a lot of our viewers a
young yeah laughs you're so yeah yeah me
on aspiring drinkers yeah so maybe gets
root beer and watch us to talk about
this movie watch us watch with the audio
adios yeah and use up all your data
your data plan yes this is your cars
time for ya what's an extra hundred yeah
enjoy enjoy what was that I said you
need Dom you will be staying and gonna
talk blog dream any titans of industry
who pass through the sacred or some sage
Chris news this guy just want to get
down on the tape there what I just want
to get that on tables you gonna
appreciate you're like weird like we a
separate piece boarding school dean
voice weird donut man stay you junior
tall it sounds like a man made me feel
dumbest it's like the classes I they
cared before the fat loss' would be with
happen yeah yeah bring me some movie
well of batch of me sure ah if we go any
further we're just gonna be we're just
gonna be reenacting the Patton Oswalt
did ya know this is going to devolve
into us quoting crow making that noise
it's gonna be like funny to us and don't
yeah it will be it'll be like one of
those obnoxious things where I imagine
Dave Chappelle went through where people
just stopped them on the street go I'm
Rick James [ __ ] like me do you do do
the beat to the beat sound you do the B
sound Pat mr. mr. Patton macaws Walt do
the sound of the blue do it do it right
here though where I am and not just on
the recording do it live give me that
thing you're paid to do professionally
give it to me right now immediately for
free [ __ ] it we'll do it live we're
doing a lot no no more memes I I locked
myself in an open grave to escape the
memes do what are you just encroaching
upon your existence everywhere just
turned the memes are hunting me just you
be being pursued by various music
chairman quarter just
right there point national yeah I turn
another Corey it's a bit another corners
a bunch of rare pet days yeah and then
at the very end like you reach a dead
end and it's just the troll face yes
like it's like it's the it's the
ultimate mean that's going to finally
kill me like at the end of this creamy
pasta that is my meme hounded life yeah
the troll face hunts me down the trophy
hunts you it's a meme and then asks why
you know something it asked me if
there's a problem and calls me officer
problem problem officer no problem just
rush hour the movies that from um um
police story duh police story under so
please started the joke here is that
both of those are Jackie Chan movies but
the first quote was from rush hour okay
and not police story okay these stories
like a like a series of you know amusing
Jackie Chan martial arts movies i can't
remember like I don't hardly is like
original Chinese movies yeah okay i
think i saw them dubbed as a kid but
there I was pregnant um is Rufus super
cop might be the one that came off of
our police story might be the one that
came off of Supercop but I can't
remember now but not one of them can
hold a candle to the tuxedo ah or the
spy next door oh let's not talk about
let's not talk about that the more
bummer II like family part of Jackie
Chan's I feel like Jackie Chan should
like be a prolific director right now
cuz he's got the chops you should just
be like the the come to Edgar Wright
from here on out that would be cool like
that I'll be down for that I just want
to see a Jackie Chan movie again that's
fun I just want to see a return form for
misters Chan for the Chan yeah the
Chairman I think we should record this
all helium vocal yeah or monster boy I
really was revered reform hey that would
work for this because then he would
sound like immortan joe yeah
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my will talk to the
turtle rostral humble fall Wow fucking's
actually it's all right mad Mac well I
didn't get the ax I'm just gonna be the
death Mad Max bro more like rad max my
breath more like good man more like
pretty good as meant more like happy max
happy max more like maybe something yeah
one day one day he'll still outrun his
demons and the rest the movies were
still home gardening yeah and just like
the various West single plant that was
the same plant across multiple movies
mad Max's gardening just to bring this
one plant to grow into a full tree yeah
this expansive wasteland desert ya know
it's just it's always him trying to
nurture this tree and then just you know
different weather conditions of sale and
besides like you know in one movie
there's another sandstorm when he's got
a protective tree from a sandstorm yeah
that's answer that sandstorm was cool
because like I'm I'm guessing that's the
most CGI heavy sequence in the movie
yeah yeah I mean there's some like
background something but yeah like this
use the CGI to delete mountains in the
background to make the desert look wider
and flatter and to delete you know
rigging and things and applying wires
and things like that which is a good use
of CGI it's well yeah what it's best for
yeah i mean this movie sort of does that
to enhance real really well insert a
fake thing yeah no I mean like this
movie i think is like the best example
of how to approach effects nowadays it's
like what can we do on camera all right
we'll do that can we do it safely yeah
all right now well what do we need can
we do is safely includes things like
saying to nicholas hoult up for this
scene don't lead your head black because
it will hit the truck tire and you'll
die yeah yeah that's that's the motto
como safeties like don't move your head
backwards at all yet for a sustained
period of time you guys saved you but it
is Lisa's like you know let's how many
of these things can we do in a way where
you won't die doing
yeah you know and then uh and then what
you know what is necessary you see
beautiful yeah what can we use it as
what's a really practical application
procedure yeah and it's like yeah you
know that that sandstorm that's where
you use the CGI set piece and it's
gorgeous the scene where ya again this
is go cross into spoiler territory
really fast but the shot were they done
these have spoilers I know some folks
don't I'm gonna try and keep notes I'm
like what we talk spoilers for in case
like we cross-reference together
weathers in these podcasts long-form
discussion yeah I entertained the last
one but yeah be prepared yeah um so I
mean this this movie had a there was
that one shot were the guitar the big
guitar rig they do for your rate crash
you worry that do for here is my life
doof warrior is my life and that shits
that's a real guitar yeah it is it would
wait like a hundred plus pounds for
although the rigging that allowed it to
shoot real gasoline-powered flames I
just I just love that story the whole
thing about like George Miller doesn't
like props that don't work so the guy
actually rigged it just in case just in
case he was like yeah plug it in like
that's impressive yeah but do for him I
do for what I want to be in the future
but there's that child where they do for
your rig the whole truck they do 40
rides on crashes and the guitar swings
right in front of the camera and that
felt so perfect yeah so I'm thinking
that's the CGI thing oh yeah yeah that's
totally a CGI did you know then I don't
know how it works but it seems like even
that you can use the real guitar and
then manipulate it yeah you scan the
real guitar or you take good good images
at the real guitar yeah looks like they
use them for a little accents and stuff
like that and it's just so nice you know
it's like it I don't just I'm just
talking a lot lately like in a lot of
things I've seen lately just the idea of
approach keeps standing out yeah I feel
like just mad magazine they approached a
lot of things the right way like they
they did the right considerations with
yeah it's um god it's like they use the
the CGI heaviest sequence is the
sandstorm and it's like that's the point
where you do want that's the point works
good to have CGI because like you can't
mock up a massive weather storm like
that yeah that sandstorm is titanic and
what it becomes almost surreal when they
go into it yeah it's it's this it's this
like eclipsing horrifying beautiful
thing and you would just never be able
like that is something where you need to
be able to manipulate you know elements
in reality with wit see you can't make
that happen you can make a practical
windstorm you can't make that happen
yeah you can't and that's like a huge I
keep comparing this movie to a symphony
and that is like a big ah like I was I
was saying I was saying like as I'm
watching this movie and I was sitting
down last night watchman's when I'm like
this thing paint with mayhem yeah yeah
it is like it's like an extremely
detailed like Rembrandt or like a
Hieronymus Bosch yeah thats painted
entirely out of mayhem mayhem and gas at
guzzoline guzzoline and rust and rot car
parts and just crashing yeah and it's
I'm surprisingly for what it is it's an
extremely intelligent movie yeah I don't
want to say for what it is but it's like
it's smarter than a lot of movies that
aren't even in a spectacle genre yeah
and in a way where it doesn't feel like
it's trying too hard in anything I mean
I don't I admire the does everything in
this movie just feels like that's just
how it is and it's all there it's in
complete command of itself yeah because
I mean it's it's not an overly complex
plot but it's the themes at work and
just you know the way certain characters
work together it's like it shouldn't
even be progressive what it is yeah and
it's i was thinking of just earlier
today it's like the difference between
this movie and say the dark knight rises
and um
hearty both oh yes a movie our cars now
um same movie know what services Todd
the dark knight rises and I liked it
when I sat down watched it but you know
as time went on I could really look back
at the jars and rice doesn't think like
yeah this had some issues yeah it's not
a perfect and now I like that I like a
lot of things about that movie that I
can see yeah it's like you did he was
kind of it felt really slapdash in a lot
of places and it's like I think the the
Chris Nolan Batman movies they it's like
their reach out seat their reach
exceeded their grasp when it came to
handling deeper more complex
socio-political issues huh it was almost
like if political complexity was liquor
and the Christopher Nolan Batman movies
would be like a teenager that's a little
too short that like grabs a chair to
stand on top of to grab the liquor from
the high cabinet and then breaks a
bottle on the ground okay and Mad Max is
like a guy with a you know a taller dude
that doesn't need to grab a chair and
gets like a smaller bottle yeah but he's
able to still get the bottle and serve
it to you okay whereas you know the
Chris Nolan Batman was just kind of make
this mess on the floor it's like the
dark knight rises in particular it's
like bein there's all this stuff we were
like bein is positioned as like a fake
pseudo populist revolutionary but none
nothing really comes of it nothing's
really said nothing's really made of it
it's just kind of there for window
dressing and like no cohesive statement
is made whereas fury road is and this
sounds crazy to say for you know a movie
about crazy car crashes and and gunplay
it's like this is a this is a movie
entirely in command of its politics ya
know took what and I think that partly
comes from like there's so much stuff
going on in the Batman movies there's
also a certain life
like well if you gotta get Batman stuff
you gotta do like the comic with you
things too yeah whereas in Mad Max
everything it at least in fury road it's
like everything kind of ties into what
life is like now yeah and it's it's
allowed to exist sort of on that level
and and and you know just the the
inception of in the way the the store in
foals is thought-out you know it's like
everything is very everything you can
tell sort of has a reason behind it yeah
you know antonino is also like the
crystal Batman movies it's one guys and
and it's like a few guys you know
Christopher and Java Nolan and David
Goyer you know the comics guy then
diving into this 80 90 year old mythos
that they have to do something that's
still faithful and saleable to where is
like yeah Mad Max is whatever the [ __ ]
George Miller wants it to be oh yeah
exactly it's like he's still the guy at
the helm at at 70 years old he's still
in charge of Mad Max it is whatever he
wants it to be yeah and rightfully so I
mean come on you're gonna [ __ ] you're
gonna you're gonna try and take Mad Max
away from the guy who directed Lorenzo's
oil out and check and babe and both
happy feet movies hey man he owns he
owns mom yeah he owns that he can do
whatever he wants and he [ __ ] make
good on it uh and and all this like
men's rights activism stuff like uh yeah
like I'm just I'm just I'm pleasantly
surprised that it's this movie we're
talking about it's like the most you
know it's just you know gearhead mayhem
and yet we have this sort of little
feminist debate swirling around it makes
me glee I was gonna say it's like movies
or feminist is [ __ ] today using
babadook ex machina and now this big
more or less like middle of the like
middle tier 10 pole movie yeah well and
it's like this movie manages to do that
in a way that doesn't call attention to
it and and it doesn't the way this movie
pulls it off it's like oh yeah it's not
even that hard or it doesn't feel like
it's that hard it makes it look easy
it's like look you you just sort of let
the characters be and work together and
you know yeah you know it's like and
when it comes to the whole joke about
like Oh Mad Max is like the big macho
bravado gearhead movie and now there's
this whole feminist reading of it I'm
thinking no cuz the whole point of the
movie is like why why isn't being a
feminist of masculine quality why isn't
that a masculine virtue like you know
believing in everyone's agency and
believing in equality and you know being
ethical like that yeah well and there's
it you know I think part of the problem
on a bigger scale is like as most people
don't know exactly what feminism is yeah
and I'm glad that there are men like us
in the world that you know we know
better than anyone because we're guys
what feminism is yet yeah it's like more
people should just listen two men one
feminism is because like we know yes
like I'm so glad like their brains like
us that takes you about like Gloria
Steinem and [ __ ] enlightened ass breasts
like British Isles four times it's like
yo Brett if you want to talk bell hooks
hit me I want to meet that guy because
one of me that exact guy it's like like
backwards baseball cap like can of
monster energy drink popped polo collar
so I don't like the other so many times
my yeah position other breath it's like
dude you're being like Tilly
phallocentric [ __ ] off of that [ __ ]
bread it's like bro we're trying to like
play some beer pong and have someone on
gender discourse come on dude stop
[ __ ] around quit being a [ __ ] boy
yeah what is a [ __ ] boy what is the [ __ ]
boy yeah ok I want to get into fuckboy a
little bit more when we talk about the
marble hornets movie I don't want to get
into [ __ ] I just love that stuff I want
to get into football more academic sense
now an NPR voice that I want to talk
about [ __ ] boy no [ __ ] black I put our
Katara so to my knowledge [ __ ] boys
become a very nebulous thing and I have
I think like the way in which [ __ ] boys
kind of evolved as a term has something
to do with the appropriation of memes
from what's called black Twitter which
is you know the kind of like an Internet
a nebulous sort of side of internets up
sure that's mostly with african-american
kids that are usually comment using you
know Twitter so this isn't like a
sonographic superhero black Twitter no
[ __ ] boy no um so I think it's so avoid
sidekick black Twitter yeah so [ __ ] boys
kind of like Duvall this kind of branch
out into multiple means and there are
different codified spellings of [ __ ] boy
and they seem to have different
connotations and this is what and this
is my guess cuz I'm kind of I'm an
outsider looking at this but trying to
look at this um deeply um on yeah sad Oh
looky and waiters Wonderwall um so has
been a very good thinking about a way
simpler one why because blurs new album
is really good I know I've heard good
things about the new Blue Book's like
blue Miller's of it this great learner
sounds to me like a band of warrants way
more attention than oasis well that's
the thing like there was the whole brick
potli i'll keep this up he'll keep this
brief then we gonna get back to so we
gotta get back to [ __ ] boy yeah and then
get back to man Thank You Megan I max
keeps track of the levels yeah but now
it's like our conversations are like in
section yes we're intercutting between
multiple levels of tangents and I want
to give a shout out to the one person
that can master our multi levels of
conversation from our common threads on
the day on the first on the first ex
machina video which is a premium
dongsaeng premium dongsaeng freemium dog
think had a comment for every topic that
we brought up and that was brilliant
dude you you've earned a shout-out yeah
premium dong saying I'm very I'm very
happy that you engaged and enjoy yeah
this is for you really so bad blur blur
not clear and oasis it's one of those
things were like blur and and vaguely
maybe always there like I'll check back
in every few years to be like I wonder
if this is more like my pant or though I
just float across my radar and like in
recent life I've become very I'd very
much admired Damon Albarn the more I've
gotten into his music you know I think a
lot of the gorilla stuff is really
brilliant oh no and even his solo stuff
is good the bad the Queen stuff it seems
like he he is one of those modern guys
who really is a force and really is sort
of a visionary that comes to music and I
and I
have recently started to appreciate the
whole unit that is blur and you know I
was compelled to pick up magic whip for
some reason and I really like like it's
a good things about it it's a really
good really mature record like and
there's a lot of different sound on it
and you know it just made me sort of go
back and think my god wonder I'm gonna
get it you know sort of research the
back catalogue and and that got into the
whole like you know you can't think
about the history of blur without
thinking of you know blur versus always
is and stuff like that I think what
makes blur ultimately a better band is
that blur is always looking forward and
Oasis is always a good always is always
trying to like find the last holding
pattern that worked no it's like Oh asus
is so beholden to the beatles like oh
yeah to the beatles into a degree like
the stone stuff so it's like you know
Noel Gallagher I like no gallery I like
some of his music and I kind of like I
tend to like his songs more on an oasis
wrecker or I'll just Ali could stand up
a lot more no Gallagher he does with
fruit yeah yeah that's right I'm the
first man watch to make that joke I'm
the first man on the planet to make that
joke high five high five well done
you've you've made history that I mean
if we're gonna be talking about this
woman's you know I'm probably not the
first guy to pick that show yeah yeah I
prefer no Gallagher to Liam Gallagher
but even so it's like I just just always
feel like blur is almost always more
interesting and and has a better like if
you look at their discography and I
still got to listen to a lot of it but
there's there's more of an interest in
the world around and in life like their
first three major arms are considered
like are called like the modern life
trilogy because they're sort of
chronicling the world around I think
there is like a world-weary you know
quality that comes with a lot of that so
you have magic whip pick it up it's
great i love it it's right album dank
ass a priest dank dank ass approved for
magic whipped [ __ ] boys now [ __ ] boys
back to [ __ ] boys alright so there are
multiple spellings of [ __ ] boys one is
at UCC bo I and that seems to be more of
the more connected to the original
sure yeah that seems to be more
connected to the original black Twitter
roots of the term and so [ __ ] boy seems
to be either like someone who's just
kind of fake and posturing and tries to
act hard whether or not that's one
version of the fucc voi so basically as
a poser yeah a poser but also someone
that's trying to like be like a street
where fashionista and looks like an
idiot with it you can find a very under
under curated tumblr called like [ __ ] a
boy of the month or [ __ ] boy of the week
we're just like you know dudes that are
trying to Alyssa trying to go for like
fashion like it's very like urban street
where like hip-hop fashion look but they
kind of look like idiots the dudes with
like running tights with pyrex shorts
over them hi Rex yeah pires is like
about a brand of like basketball short
of breath glass bowls yes I'm aware of
the cookware pyrex that's what makes the
Pyrex short thing so hilarious um
supreme is like a like a hot a hot
concept with is like a hot brand with
the [ __ ] boy set that [ __ ] boy said so
that's that's one version of [ __ ] put
the other version of [ __ ] boy is more of
the white the white [ __ ] boy ok ok so
the white [ __ ] boy i think is what
happens when the bro and the hipster
have been found out and because they've
been found out they're trying to hide
themselves in some new aesthetic and one
in some new subculture and because of
that they're kind of meeting in the
middle so the [ __ ] boy the fu ck bo why
um it's like on one hand you have
upscale like upper upper middle yeah
yeah Jerry's looking at that [ __ ] boy of
the day and there's this joker who looks
yeah you know the skinny jeans with like
a skirt type basketball short weird
thing over it and ostentatious chains
and just like over designed everything
ok so the I hate culture culture is my
life um if you see
KBOI so my understanding and I'm I could
be totally off with all of this so you
have like upper middle class white
college boy um uh kind of the kind of
guys that are you like an Elite daily
fan oh boy yeah shout out I feel like
we're gonna find a reason to shout out
to illegally buck you for binge for
being for being the worst so it's like
watch what they're gonna sponsor it yeah
I don't want I just want to be sponsored
by but always some of the issues i don't
like yeah I want to get hash pork leave
daily a return of kings what is why it's
them it's a men's rights activist nog
hey you you want to know tangled knot
with monsters lest ye become monstrous
dude no but it hurts it hurts me t I'm
sorry yeah that's part of it it's like
most people who are against feminism
don't understand what it is and like
granted it's kind of hard to understand
what it is just because there are so
many sort of splintery factions that all
kind of approach it different than
there's a huge propaganda like effort
for you know straw feminism people try
to like make up what feminism is yeah
and like you to lambast in to try and
undercut it and to the best of my
understanding as I've been told you know
by people who have studied it more than
I have it's like feminism is simply like
the striving for equality between people
it's not it's not tipping the scale so
that women have all power or whatever
it's not some kind of militant takeover
it's just how about we all be equal yeah
and then all have annual opportunities
now if you really if you really want to
make that argument yet there are people
that you know under the banner of
feminism are saying kill all men or
whatever but that's not that's not real
feminine that's not this one that's not
a real version of the ideology or the or
the stance a and B those people aren't
the core of it those people are on the
fringe and every like any and every
movement any and every sort of group or
organization will have one of those yeah
it's like I mean just because
like yeah they're there were probably
some people involved in like the
abolitionist movement who were kind of
[ __ ] that doesn't mean that you know
slavery was right yeah exactly like just
because there were people that were
abolitionists in the 1860s who were kind
of rude yeah it's like hey [ __ ]
exist and every group will have a couple
what you know whether or not the group
as a whole is morally or ethically in
the right yeah and and that shouldn't
take away from the greater implication
so so to wrap up [ __ ] boy the [ __ ] boy
in the the fu ck Bo I the the the white
[ __ ] ploy for lack of a better term
that's more like bros are trying to be
more classy and hipsters are trying to
be more corporate and mainstream and in
the middle there creating the [ __ ] boy
who is so you know [ __ ] boy it's people
use [ __ ] boy in that sense a lot of
times just to done just to donate like
in or just to Dennett eight or notate or
whatever the [ __ ] the word is just like
a gross ass white dude but as a click or
as a subculture that kind of [ __ ] boy is
like you know pastel polo and chino
shorts and boat shoes and you know
texting girls on tinder and like asking
what's your cup size and thinking that
constitutes is flirting I like that [ __ ]
cuz it's like I follow allah i saw a
blog called them straight white boys
texting work that's just everywhere do
try to pick up chicks or just like so
how big are your boobs I'm like why do
you need to know her factory specs are
you trying to build one of her yourself
well in that like that communicates
dislike this is very this is physical
like right up front if like there there
are no deeper into it's not even like
it's not even physical in like oh you're
pretty its physical and be like what are
your specification yeah itself its axon
are you going to are you going to order
like another one just like her off of
newegg or sometimes it's checking off
like it's checking out specs its
mechanical and mathematical in a really
stupid way
uh what are you going to say like what
like what are you going to say if she
gives you an answer is like how big your
ruse of 32 double D cool that's a number
do you mind pleased that my require it's
a princess right it's like what the [ __ ]
it's like what are you guys a um uh your
band size could be smaller what it's
like what the [ __ ] i'll go ahead and
then come back maybe we'll go to the
maybe we'll see fury road maybe we'll
see except i'm boycott are you
boycotting it though because because the
return of kings forum says I should why
do they have to ruin cool cars with
estrogen yeah it's like the urban
dictionary definition fuckboy a week a
person who is a week as a [ __ ] that
ain't about [ __ ] I mean this very vague
that's very vague I just loudly specific
because I mean it's a nebulous term so
it encapsulates a lot of things yeah um
you might be a [ __ ] boys I did that I'm
made of I made that hashtag you might be
a [ __ ] boy if dude ah i was i was
watching you i was watching a lot of
those it didn't make a good giggle yeah
I wasn't simultaneously like what are
you talking like it cuz i keep here but
i feel like hearing it I feel like a
[ __ ] boys like the matrix yeah it has to
be described to you before it's defined
and then you'll see once I'm I described
it to you then you'll see that yeah hose
be like oh man uh-oh here we go thought
catalog how many signs he's a [ __ ] boy
i'm not i'm not a click bait fan by any
stretch of the imagination but these
these this is a handy definition of the
[ __ ] boy term and I think everyone's
gonna need to learn this because [ __ ]
boys on the rise one he's constantly
begging for new zest yeah two he doesn't
believe in label he says he doesn't
believe in labels three he disrespects
his mother that's [ __ ] or he never
wants to be seen a public of you five
he's his terms like bros before hoes and
hose be like yeah when you see a white
dude that's always talking about a hose
it's like shut up man he has no ambition
no you have no idea how many
our other women in his life he blows up
your plans to hang out with slides into
your direct messages he talks [ __ ] about
all of his exes or says they were quote
crazy that's something that I've noticed
whenever someone's like always talking
about crazy exes and really wants to
talk about crazy exes all the time I
kind of feel like I won't say what did
you do to drive them crazy yeah you're
focusing attention back on yourself dude
if you've got to talk about it that much
you know it's like you're trying to
convince yourself or the people around
you so fancy way yeah everyone and I
mean it's like everyone falls prey to
this i know i've fallen prey to this but
it's like winning when a relationship
goes sour eventually you got to stop
putting everything off on the other
person and like look back and accept
your part in this well yeah and if
you're if you're of a certain age it's
no longer it's no long time excusable
that you haven't nutted up an accepted
responsibility yeah it's like few few
situations are one-sided especially in
any romantic like pursuit it's like you
know they the scales might be tipped
perhaps but I mean everybody's a
contributor everyone everyone is a tango
er yeah and the thing about tango is
that requires some number of people that
escapes me at the moment tango of are
you referring to the major Hollywood
motion picture of 310 is that starring
Matthew Perry and some Hollywood's
Matthew Perry Matthew Perry of Matthew
Perry fan well she's right stays human
from the rousing discussion about three
to tango yeah and then we'll get back to
Mad Max oh yeah no um let's get back to
Mad Max get bags Mad Max although it did
at Matthew ferry and dylan mcdermott and
neb camp Hollywood's dylan mcdermott and
holly was oliver platt dylan mcdermott
vexes me because that made doesn't age
he doesn't but i can tell him apart from
Dermot Mulroney very easily so I can you
tell apart from Clive Owen yeah Oh telly
I do they have they have vaguely similar
facial features there
are similarly shaped ya know they do i'm
not saying that there is no similarity
there but i like I get it by the same
time it's like once you know the
difference really well they'll never
look similar once you know the
difference between between Clive oh and
and dylan mcdermott you'll see the
differences everywhere you go exactly
and darling Laura in terminal I loved
remember oh do you yeah I like Dermot
Mulroney what I always enjoy seeing him
in major motion pictures really excited
that he's in cities through busy yeah
boom dad insidious her oh boy that's my
boy so back to man man act man max okay
so back to Mad Max um oh it is good oh
there I saw something interesting it was
uh granted you know it's like it was a
cursory glance that I saw I think it the
chance to read the whole thing but you
know the Internet's favorite feminist
thinker Anita sarkeesian wait for those
frequency yeah she said I saw mad max I
see why everyone likes it but it's not
feminist and you know in as much as
anyone can make a cogent argument in 140
character chunks with the limits of
Twitter I I can see her points because
basically it's like you know two main
points she may were like you know even
though the movie features the the you
know badass women who were quote-unquote
empowered it's still the camera still
looks at the wives kind of leering Lee
and it's gleeful about violence and and
doesn't take the vaya it doesn't show
the violence to be tragic it indulges in
the violence and I think and you know as
a man I know everything about feminism
so I'm right um no just like can you
imagine how gross that would be like I
do that sincerely is like mansplaining
feminists feminism to feminists a dance
plane yeah it's like dude homeboy is
missing the vote yeah but um was i say
it's like um
I think what people forget like it's
like a you know feminism is an active
process everyone does their feminism
differently home it's like you know
everyone drinks but everyone drinks
something different everyone has a
different favorite drink yeah everyone
who does feminism has a different way of
going about it I think with Mad Max it's
you can take two different readings of
it one it's it's you can take a little
reading of the violence that the pro
female characters indulgent isn't about
violence for violence's sake its
violence to counter atrocity is violence
to their engaging in the violence to
counter it because running from it is
not the option and then it's also the
fact that this is a movie and I think
like in a good someone who makes a good
action movie the way George Miller did
understands that cinema violence at its
core is supposed to be symbolic the
thing about movies is that they're
they're extremely limited in their
ability to show internal states that's
their their Achilles heel yeah in a lot
of ways they have to physicalize and and
and visualize everything yeah a movie
excels when it takes some internal idea
and turns it into physical action so
it's like in a movie like fury road that
is indulging in a or in dealing with a
very heady concept of your personhood
and agency and and you know female
liberation it happen you know the fact
that it's this big crazy whacked-out
post apocalyptic genre is got to find a
way to interact with that concept only
in the language of physical action yeah
so that physical action isn't about just
beating the [ __ ] out of people that
physical action is symbolic yeah no I
mean that that makes that means it's all
the embodiment of a very specific
struggle you know it's all right i feel
like that
when the movie plays out is very sort of
media dance like that you know the
meaning of the struggle is very much you
know it is a fight both theoretically
and in reality you know it's like it's
she has stolen his property yeah and the
property just isn't proper it isn't one
ya like I remember I I saw the original
trailer for fury road the original
teaser I was like okay yeah this looks
like you know crazy whacked-out car
chases and then i saw i think it was
like you and ryan and then it is like
reacting to a later trailer where
immortan joe just says I want them back
through my property and you see the
property are these women and I'm just
like this is really [ __ ] loaded yeah
but that's an interesting idea it's like
is there it's like I'm interested in
this movie because it feels like it's
gonna be some kind of like there's gonna
be some accidental you know feminist
text in here and then it's like oh this
is an accidental at all yeah well I mean
they they went on their way to consult
and stuff like that into really yeah you
know make sure I don't know I get her
argument like I get that you know it's
like we should you know our are the sort
of um you get Sarkisian's argument yeah
I get one side it's like yeah you know
we should be able to I've even heard the
benefit of the doubt just because lord
knows this woman needs people giving her
the benefit of the doubt instead of
saying that she's evil in trying to
destroy the world ya know for sure and I
and I mean I've I've you know uh at
least mart like sort of following her
stuff for a while now I've been aware of
her presence for a while a nice room you
know stumble across her pieces now and
again um I get it on the one hand side
yeah you know we should have you no more
a broader range of feminist messages and
ideas beyond just like women can kick
ass and blow stuff up to you know but at
the same time I feel like this movie
does it I'm not an authority of feminism
but like you know I feel like this movie
in the way that it incorporates it does
it the right way you know because it's
like furiosa is tough and you know I
think she said something about you know
like killing people stoically but
there's a lot of emotion there like they
she's tough and
and rough and tumble but she's also not
not a woman it's like a lot of a lot of
these a lot of movies that want a woman
and make them ostensibly a man whereas
furious is still a woman and the wives
for instance each wife has a moment and
there they may seem cursory they may
seem like shortly may seem like you know
just one off but each wife has a moment
where you see them become empowered they
develop a skill yeah and that skill is
not necessarily about like how well they
can shoot how well they can beat up guys
there their skills are all you know like
diplomacy or or or you know the I really
like to turn with the one wife and I
can't remember her name cuz you know
this isn't a movie that's big on like
setting up everyone by name but there's
the wife that initially kind of has this
learned helplessness thing words like
when they're stranded in the desert she
wants it like run back yeah 22 immortan
joe's convoy and like ask for
forgiveness and then at the end she's
the one that fake surrender yeah that
allows everything to come to a head at
the end of the big car tration that's
that's brilliant she know the fragile
chido the fragile it's in it makes sense
she's the fragile one she's the one that
that is terrified of having to rough it
because even though she's imprisoned
she's at least seemingly pampered and
given some some privilege at immortan
joe's behalf but it's like she she has a
cool art and um I'm trying to go who
else like uh like oh who's the one that
that looked kind of like Daenerys
Targaryen yeah the one with the very
pale blond hair this the one who's kind
of strange but the she's the more
spiritual ways one who prays who is she
capable I know the dag the dag capable
as the redhead Abby Lee Abby Lee plays
the dag the dad she becomes the new
keeper of the seeds she's like the new
the news like uh implicitly she's the
new spiritual leader she's the new
agricultural leader it's like they don't
have
they don't have to like getting a
bare-knuckle brawl but there they go
from being helpless you know mcguffin's
to becoming active characters when they
rise to the occasion whenever it's
needed it's like they're not just
damsels that are not just helpless it's
like they all know respond to situations
like they all act in one way or another
and what this movie gets really well is
like you know being a good being heroic
being the the you know wandering hero
like max being a good person isn't about
just rescuing someone who's helpless
it's about making someone taking
someone's who's helpless in giving them
what they need so they never have to be
helpless again yeah let's sort of seems
to be like a big I mean that's that
becomes the ultimate goal to just beyond
beyond furious and the way that becomes
like the whole reason for the plan that
becomes the salvations going back giving
you know creating community by giving
you know these people who are you know
basically at the whim of Joe and it
would be like you know giving them an
actual life giving them something as
basic as water yeah you know and in
modern Joe's such a such a fantastic
villain because it's like he's he is
such a such a bastard in that sense of
like needing to aspire to this godlike
thing I was gonna say um you know and
it's like it is also when you you read
as like you know I'm gonna get back to
this info later but I think you can read
this whole movie as a manual on how to
dismantle patriarchy Hey yeah and I'm
serious about that I'm one hundred
percent serious when I say mad max fury
road is a step-by-step is a step-by-step
manual on how to how to dismantle
patriarchy okay um okay so it's like an
immortan joe is brilliant cuz Scott like
he's got that very baked in brilliant
visual metaphor works like he postures
as being godlike but everything about
him is for show he's got plastic armor
that makes him look ripped when he's
just this giant tumor yeah he'll
oh yeah the first time you mean I was a
little taken aback and sounds like I
thought I thought I was buffing he's
like this kind of doughy doughy tumor
doubt guy and they put his arm around
with the pecs and abs molded in yeah and
his you know various metals and ribbons
that mean nothing yeah and then he
literally has a mask on yeah sounds like
ya it's a gas match that makes it looks
fearsome but really you realize it's a
mask it it does literally what a mask
does and said it conceals what he is and
makes him be presentable as something
else yeah and it makes you know
formidable yeah like on top of all that
this is a world tour like like appearing
fearsome in appearing like somebody i
think somebody expressed the opinion
that this is almost in terms of like
feminism and patriarchy is like this is
almost the future were like all the
worst possible outcomes of all the most
masculine qualities have been free to
run amok yeah it is it is a movie about
toxic masculinity versus positive
masculinity or just or just human
decency yeah and I like I again I'm not
I'm not the expert but I felt like they
did a decent job of giving masculine and
feminine qualities both to the female
carriage most of Max cuz his max is kind
of I mean he's kind of like I mean he's
presented to be like kind of crazy when
he first starts in encountering the
wives in furiosa yeah he's kind of like
a junkyard dog yeah and I mean you know
he always looks kind of uncomfortable
and and tired yeah and I mean just as
just as a micro thing like I always
enjoy he's been having a really shitty
day up to the point where he finally
meets them there's something about that
i really like just as its own little
detail just like Mad Max just looks
tired you just kind of sick of this like
I just led this like my favorite shot in
the movie where um where was her name
the the pregnant wife the splendid
splendid Angharad when when they crash
into that rock formation he looks back
to see if she's still there and she kind
of ducks back out of the space between
the the back of the trailer and the
front of the truck and he
the thought gives her that like yeah I
was just like a weary thumbs up yeah
it's like a good job like like we're all
having a shitty day of a good job like I
just say like true real real talk bat
full sequence and yet again spoiler
warning that whole sequence first of all
that whole sequence is like the classic
midpoint sequence in like traditional
screenplay structure and it's the best
yeah it is it is the moment where max
and furios have finally really worked
together it's the moment where the wives
start all stepping up to the plate and
and start casting off their their sense
of helplessness and like actually fight
back specifically like mostly splendid
but there's this and it's also the scene
where immortan joe and the war boys as
well as the bullet farmer and his war
party and the the Baron of gas town in
his party are all converging on them
yeah and so this it's like a very
wonderful you know as far as the subtext
of it and in the philosophy of it it
hits all the right notes because there's
this one shot there's this one shot
where for you know you see the war
parties coming in and then there's a
close-up of splendid pregnant belly and
you and it's like in that moment I got
like I've never been more emotional at a
movie that I can remember in recent
history because it's like there's the
moment where you know you see immortan
joe and the the gas town guy and the
bullet farmer just like yer these three
monsters these three [ __ ] idiots and
it's also right after one of the wives
telling knucks the the sickly war boy
that kind of joins her party later she's
telling him who killed the world yeah
and so it's like so you see these three
idiots that are going to destroy
everything in the search of some fake
[ __ ] thing called cower yeah and
then there's that shot of splendid and
here's
this is the one thing that really
matters this is life this is hope this
is the one thing that's going to rebuild
the world and you three [ __ ] yeah
are going to kill it I'm going to
destroy it for some fake [ __ ] yeah
that you believe is what is what makes
you feel for your masks and your
pageantry and your costumes and your in
your nonsense you are going to kill the
one thing that's real so you can keep
play-acting in your [ __ ] [ __ ]
desert and stay at the top of your water
tower until and play soldier yeah like
that that whole sequence was brilliant
and then it's like when splendid dies it
was just [ __ ] yeah well I'm like that's
the thing that lets such a great toy
like they told her through that moment
because it's like they careen through
that rock formation you're like oh
there's there's no way she could live
through that and then she does in your
life alright and then and then they
still that character still dies yeah and
that sort of lost the moment where you
realize like oh this world like it's the
movie with like the the movie illusion
breaks to to a degree where you're like
so safety is not guaranteed you know for
necessarily for our for our characters
for our heroes for you know for these
yeah it's like and they all and and it's
the the pregnant one yeah it's a one who
arguably in American cinema would have
to survive the one that would have to
survive because she's the got the
high-stakes pregnancy and one she's the
one up to that point that was ostensibly
the leader of the wives yeah it hardly
has to do with it I that she's the one
that's closest to having another kid on
the way she's got the most to lose right
now yeah but up into that point it's
like she's the one that the wives all
seem to listen to she's the one that
that runs the show more or less she's
one that the other wives take take their
you know take their their cues from and
so she seems to be the most prominent
but no she's out she's out of the
[ __ ] picture yeah yeah and then I
mean further further than that guys like
the otherwise have to know have to
further rally
beyond that yeah step up beyond that
that's like a motivator for them yeah
but like ah see the thing is like I get
that complaint of like uh you know like
it shouldn't have to be all violence
stuff like that but I feel like the more
sort of the more equal things get at
least in a cinematic landscape more sort
of the feminist ideals it's like yeah
this movie might not be the movement but
i think it's it's really well in that
sort of circle of artistic expression of
you know I feel like Mad Max fury road
it does it's feminism really well but
just like any mainstream movie it's only
like it's like you know feminism 101
yeah I mean and it's a really it matches
the movie it's a lightly good it's a
really good day of feminism 101 but
don't think like this is like this isn't
the moo you show to the world to change
but it is a good like entry point it's
Lana hey this looks a lot like the stuff
you love except look we can do it with
you equality too and it's also is going
down to brass tacks of like hey women
people yeah nun things yeah exactly it's
like give them some kind of agency and
some capability you know just portray
them as that and like I do think it's
like I've heard the complaint that it's
like the camera Google's the wives and I
feel like that's that's one of those
things that kind of will strike people
differently yeah cuz I didn't quite see
it that way and I get it because of
scantily clad yeah it makes sense that
because that seem like they're escaping
a place where they were just you know
sexual objects yeah it's like there's a
reason furiosa like furiosa is not
scantily clad by any stretch you know
she's never that's not her that's not
her that's not the station she's running
from she's running from the station of
being a a complicit soldier yeah and the
other women like in the city so
everyone's like in robes and and you
know turbines or like hoods you know
it's like it makes it just makes sense
that the wives would have would just be
shrouded in these you know very pristine
white but not overly you know covering
cuz they're trophies as well you know
and you know it's like that makes sense
to the world and I mean they're allowed
some sexuality because like to take all
that away what else
to be wrong but I didn't feel like the
movie for Michaels I didn't feel like
the movie was like ash I got how hot
they are yeah i think it's i think it's
a matter of and this is a bigger cut
this is a bigger argument that's been
going on forever and as far as like a
brain in the standpoint of anita
sarkeesian i know like you know she's
got people that say like yeah i need to
start accusing doesn't quite her
discourse isn't very sex positive when
you look at it that's an argument people
make I'm not going to weigh in yeah but
but it's like you know that eight oral
arguments like just because someone is
shown to be sexually attractive or shown
to have sexuality or shown to have shown
in a sexualized context does that take
away from their agency because it's like
I mean is that possible I mean is there
a way to present someone I mean and this
is not even that's been going on forever
and I think it's like you know people
answer it with things like the idea of
like feminist porn or things like that
because it means like just because when
you when you free women or you you give
women complete agency and complete you
know self-determination they don't stop
being sexual yeah well I'm I've met some
girls in my day they like sex yeah yeah
you know they like a sex yeah like
they've enjoyed the sex or to the women
I've talked to well that's that's why
it's actually that's we talked about it
during the sex yeah that's that's what
they held up a cards again 745 uh that's
this part of the trouble for me just
approaching a feminist debate and
approaching the it's like I'd like to be
able to call myself a feminist but I
feel like that that invites everyone to
be like oh yeah like you know but it's
it's it's a hard debate to me because I
feel like to a degree everyone's got a
different flavor and I can never do
there's like there's no one once you get
past the big block ideas of like you
know gender age you know let's sexuality
like a koala
leave for you know just the equality
thing yeah it comes a very difficult
debate like that's why you know you can
make a Mad Max movie that's about just
basic female agency and and you know
being anti sex slavery you can make a
Mad Max movie that's being anti sex
slavery really easily I don't know how
easily you can make in a Mad Max movie
that's about that is directly about rape
culture or directly about you know the
the perpetuation of misogyny through
sexist jokes because those things are so
so much more complex and so much more
talky and so much more abstract yeah I
man feeling the phone the feminist
undertones in this movie match the movie
they matched the story and they do take
a point of view and they drive that
point of view home I don't know I don't
think it necessarily has to be
everything and I hope more films can
come along and tackle the more complex
size of these things but the more
complex size of these things I feel like
you're going to be in a movie closer to
Earth closer to now yeah closer to
regular situations like I think this
movie really has a handle on that
ideology and how it applies to its own
world like that is the feminist or you
would tell in this world and it matches
like just and that that crosses back
over into just an art thing it's like
that's what matches here like that's and
it does go to show I think it's a nice
injury point because this is right now
the kind of movie that is everywhere all
the time you have spectacle not even
this kind of post apocalypse movie but
just saw Texaco inspection driven temple
movie yeah is everywhere and I and I
feel like this is a nice a really nice
entry point for subverting things you
know like like these sort of sexist yeah
our second like equality problematic
movies and also you know just the
regular sort of Hollywood conventions as
well it subverts a lot of those things
just by being what it is and I don't
know like I always find that there's a
certain level of any time something is
loud and for being progressive in one
way or another there's always sort of
the follow-up argument of like well it's
not progressive enough yeah or it's not
progressive in the right
way yeah it's it's progressive in this
way but when it's progressive in this
way actually accidentally is regressive
in this other way yeah and I sort of
feel like at a certain point we should
just get a lot of progressive things
together instead of putting all of
progress on one place all the time yeah
cuz like I just see that for a lot of
like anytime anything is praised for
being progressive there is a chorus for
well it's not progressive and efforts
not the right kind of progressive and
it's like well progress is progress
though I like I mean hopefully this can
open a door for something even more
progressive yeah like you know people
could say yeah it's you know there's a
lot of female agency in it but it's
still like for instance you can argue is
like yeah it's great that there were
rules that were genuinely given to
people of varying levels of disability
is great that there were rules for
amputees in there but still for the most
part people with degenerative illnesses
or people who are amputees they're kind
of portrayed as these pathetic wretches
they're not they're not really door
being kept down by Morton Joe granted
the more than Joe's keeping down
everybody yeah cuz that's what he does
but it's like you know you kind of want
to see you know you kind of want to see
people with the I guess maybe now then
I'm making I'm playing devil's advocate
against my Devils advocacy already I
guess that means I'm paying Jesus is
that if the kid I don't know at this
point but it's like you could say yes
it's cool that it's like yes it's cool
that they cast amputee actors but the
amputee actors are just shown to be this
these impoverished wretches but it's
like you know everyone is an
impoverished wretch under immortan joe's
thumb yeah it's a once they dispose
immortan joe suddenly those people can
be empowered and uplifted too yeah well
I even even immortan joe's like you know
the army of people who believe so
heavily to him it's like you know really
they're just his tools you know you're
like it's nobody nobody except him has
any sort of power status you know real
standing around at all yeah so i thought
i thought the character of nuts was a
really brilliant addition yeah he a
knucks is i feel like in Huck's is like
it's almost like the movie knew that
there was going to be like nerdy mr a's
on you
angry at the boobie and so knucks is
them yeah nux played brilliantly by
nicholas hoult he's the guy who says
what a lovely day in the trailer and I
thought he was just gonna be like a
random war boy yeah and then the fact
that it becomes like such a prominent
tertiary characters so cool because like
he shows the change he shows the change
of someone who is complicit and believes
in this whole glory through violence
glory through servitude belief in the
belief in the myth of the toxic
masculinity that immortan joe espouses
he's bought that hook line and sinker
and he's already insecure because he's
sickly yeah and has no and feels like he
is a failure of a true war boy or a true
man yeah and he wants to prove himself
entertained that glory and get that
self-worth in Valhalla get that Valhalla
and then it's like no it was all
[ __ ] you were fed a line of [ __ ]
and then at the end of his life because
he was terminally ill and so it's like
he finally gets his ride into Valhalla
for something real in or something real
something that means you know if that
means something more than just propping
up the same old [ __ ] yeah and that I
mean I thought that was a brilliant
addition I love the character of nuts
well and watching again to like I'm
because I've seen it twice that like
there's I go see it again little things
like that make even more sense the
second time because it's like you you
catch on some some more the dialogue and
things it's like and knucks has that
illusion he catches and loses it it's
broken for him like three separate times
yeah the time she finds him sort of
despond it in the back of the Warleggan
finds him yeah by the time capable finds
him in the back of the war rig it's like
I get it now like like this is a guy
who's kind of lost who has had his
illusions shattered who's who has
nothing nowhere is just nowhere now like
you know man without country and then
you know he's also shown like the first
lick of compassion anyone has ever shown
in that shame you know and that sort of
that transition is it plays out all the
better the second time and also to like
the second time I noticed just the
subtle brilliance in how they build the
trust between Max and furiosa over time
yeah because that is like really
well handled just because they know it
all just makes sense and watching him
sort of like confiscate all the guns
it's sort of like then you realize I oh
of course he's gonna go out because he
can keep the guns and he can go make
sure things are okay he's not gonna get
bamboozled on top of the truck you know
it's just like watching these different
scenes play out where they have to get
closer to each other yeah you know art
it's also the fact like when he goes out
to check the truck it's like he's
showing her trust because it's like he's
leaving her in the truck alone free to
prep a weapon while he's out yeah
exactly free to print that that nice and
the sticky yeah wait I gotta say this
movie is brilliant with the Chekhov's
gunning because like the bolt cutters
yeah are like the are like a character
and of themselves because of how much
you're able to do and the knife in the
indie gear shift it comes back over and
over again yeah that's what I mean again
people are saying like Oh Matt Matt you
know people don't get it like Mad Max
has no plans i know it has a plot and
the plot is physical it's a very
physical laws in effect yeah it's very
physical plot here's a goal and here's
the cause and effect that gets in the
way on the way to that goal yeah like
it's this it's simple and lean but it
does simple and lean really well with a
lot of thought and a lot of sense yeah
and it also seems like you know it's
simple it's simple and lean and it's
it's spread out of bunks amongst
multiple protagonists hmm furiosa is
just as much a protagonist as Max and
and nuts has an argument of himself each
wife has an arc um I've heard complaints
I capable is kind of just there to be
Knox's um to be nuts his love interest
but I feel like capable is is a sign of
of not just like being nuts his love
interest for that brief moment but she
is like she's almost like the diplomat
of the group she is kind of a show that
the group as a whole is going to be able
to impact change in the Citadel in
immortan joe's civilization she can
reach someone that's under immortan
joe's thumb and turned them around and
weigh him up uh-huh so in that sense
she's not just a love interest she's
diplomatic she's nurturing she's she's
the negotiator yeah
one and two like going back to the sort
of portrait of it's like you then you
have the first mother's the end who are
all likes or wrapped up and stuff like
then there's even a moment like i enjoy
didn't sexualize that moment where the
woman's in the tower the sort of bait
moment yeah it's like there's no ugly
moment that goes with that and then she
hits on a robber it's fine you know yeah
it's almost like she's she's starts
often it's almost like and I've heard I
read summer and I didn't get a chance to
read like but people are talking about
how the way in which the wiser first
encountered when their gauze DUP and
their and Max first meets them and their
bathing in their drinking water from the
stores in the war rig and it's supposed
to be like a I think it's the Iliad or
no I think it's like The Odyssey works
like it's supposed to harken back to old
Greek ideas of the Wildman encountering
the fair maidens bathing in the woods
and it's subverts with the expectation
that that's playing off of because he's
not getting lured in by the sexuality
yeah he's not getting lured in by the
sexuality it's like they're not there to
lure him bisexuality yeah and I guess
maybe that's another that's another
reading you can take the same way with
you know the woman that's with the the
you know furiosus old clan at the end
she's nude a top of tower calling out in
mamak says that's a trap and she goes
out and come in and interacts with her
and tells her her lineage and it's like
that's you know she's a beacon for other
members of the clan yeah it's like that
that misogynist insecurity works like
you know you know your men's rights
activist or whatever seems to think like
a women are trying to lure you in by the
power they have over the your boner and
they're going to lure you astray it's
like this insecure fear of of women's
dastardly wiles or whatever its
subverting that Maxie's it's a trap it's
like no it's a call to two allies you
know and maybe that's you take that back
to the initial idea of like sex positive
feminism it's like sexuality isn't about
sexuality doesn't have to be about about
or one first of all maybe sex is a thing
people do yeah first of all nudity does
not equate to sexuality a ya be
sexuality is not adversarial yeah it's
not supposed to be adversarial it's
supposed to be cooperative it's supposed
to be communicative it's supposed to be
communal yeah well yeah is this
something that the people greet you you
argue leurs should only engage in any
sort of sexual situation if everybody is
fully for it is unworthy so you don't
have sex with somebody to win over them
it's not a conquering yeah and I mean I
like I guess the the issues that the
people sort of touched upon with the
sexuality it's like I I never thought
any of it was early because like there's
one close up there but that's to
highlight the chastity vows yeah this
awful looking chastity but with spices
on it yeah and then there's another like
pan down on on Oh what is your name
again um on yes blended yeah it's funny
there's no they announced planet but
even that is to go like oh wait you know
just in case you missed it that's her
pregnant belly like yes there is
something very fragile and very
pressures at stake here yeah so it's
like I don't know maybe it's just the
way I watched it like I'm sure you could
view it as being sort of lecherous but I
didn't find that from them I didn't find
that to be intentional yeah and I mean
granted it's like yeah you know it's a
movie they're gonna catch pretty people
in the movie eh oh it makes sense for
his wives to be pretty yeah cuz it's
like you know this guy's the chauvinist
prince yes like it's like he would it
would be they would probably only be
chosen for the fact that they are fair
and pretty you know my fertile infertile
yet like um you know it's decided well
it feels like everything in in here is
is you know crafted with an eye and with
it a very cognizant sense for what it's
doing you know it's like everything
seems like it's there for a purpose you
know everything's got a soul you know
yeah exactly i'm got soul i'm super been